اعلن يحيى سريع الناطق العسكري باسم جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين استهداف السفينه
غرافيا التي كانت متجهه لموانئ اسرائيليه
وجدد سريع تاكيد موقع جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين مواصله استهداف السفن
الاسرائيليه والمتوجه الىى اسرائيل واتخاذ
كافه الاجراءات لتاكيد التضامن مع الشعب
الفلسطيني نفذت القوات البحريه في القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه بعون الله تعالى
عمليه استهداف لسفينه
غرافيا كانت متجهه الى موانئ فلسطين
المحتله وذلك بعدد من الصواريخ البحريه
المناسبه وكانت الاصابه مباشره وجاءت
عمليه الاستهداف بعد رفض طاقم السفينه
النداءات التحذيريه منها الرسائل
التحذيريه الناريه ان القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه مستمره في تنفيذ قرار منع الملاحه
الاسرائيليه او المرتبطه بالعدو
الاسرائيلي في البحرين الاحمر والعربي حتى
وقف العدوان ورفع الحصار على الشعب
الفلسطيني الصامد في قطاع غزه ان القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في اتخاذ كافه
الاجراءات الدفاعيه
والهجوميه ضمن حق الدفاع المشروع عن اليمن
العزيز وتاكيدا على استمرار التضامن
العملي
مع الشعب الفلسطيني
المظلوم وقبل قليل اكدت القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه ان سفينه الجغرافيه التي ترفع
علم مالطا تعرضت لقصف لكنها واصلت الابحار
عبر البحر الاحمر من جانبه قال مسؤول
امريكي للجزيره ان القوات الامريكيه قصفت
مواقع في اليمن تابعه لجماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين صباح هذا اليوم واضاف المسؤول ان
الضربه استهدفت اربعه صواريخ بلسيه مضاد
للسفن تابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين كانت
معده للاطلاق كما اوضح المسؤول الامريكي
ان الضربه الامريكيه جاءت ردا على قيام
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين الاثنين
باستهداف ناقله الحاويات جبر تار
ايجل معنا الان من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره
فادي منصور معنا كذلك من صنعاء مراس
الجزيره محمد العطاب ابدا معك محمد العطاب
من الواضح يعني هذه فحوى هذه الرسائل
باستهداف الحوثيين جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين السفينه سفينه الحاويات
الامريكيه بالامس
واليوم السفينه الاخرى المتجهه الى موانئ
فلسطين المحتله لكن يعني الى اي مد يمكن
ان يستمر الحوثيون على نفس هذا
النهج يبدو انه بعد يعني 48 ساعه او اقل
منها من استهداف الامريكي البريطاني
لمواقع جماعه انصار الله هنا نشاهد ان
القوات المسلحه التابعه لجماعه انصار نفذت
عمليه اخرى استهدفت فيها سفينه زوغ رافيا
والتي كانت متجهه الى ميناء حيفا حسب
تصريح المصادر هنا وان هذه
العمليه استخدم فيها عددا من الصواريخ
وكان وتحذيرها وكانت ايضا اطلاق ناري
للتحذير فهم الان لازالوا يستطيعون
استخدام قدراتهم لمنع السفن الذاهبه او
المتجهه الى الموانئ الاسرائيليه مؤكدين
ايضا استمرار دعمهم ومساندتهم الان يرفعون
سقف الدعم والمسانده الى مستوى انهم ليس
فقط يطالبون بدخول الغذاء والدواء الان
يطالبون بانهاء العدوان الاسرائيليه على
غزه وايضا رفع الحصار كليا هنا نشهد
تصعيدا من قبل جماعه انصار الله فيما كان
في
السابق مطالبهم فقط لدخول الدواء والغذاء
فيما يطالب ولا يزال يطالب اهالي غزه
بدخول هذه الادويه كما سمعنا في التقارير
السابقه والوضع الانساني المذري في مناطق
غزه هنا ايضا يؤكد جماعه انصار الله بان
موقفهم الانساني لن يثني اي استهداف وان
هذه فقط هي عمليات حسب توصيفهم او
والعمليه الكبرى والتي يصفونها بانها
ستكون كبيره ومؤلمه لم تاتي بعد شكرا لك
ابقى معنا محمد العطاب اتحول اليك فادي
منصور قف لنا على موقف الامريكيين مما
يجري ومن استمرار الحوثيين باستهداف تلك
السفن وكما وصف محمد العطاب
يعني برفع السقف من قبله فيما يتعلق بتلك
الضربات
نعم الولايات المتحده اليوم ووفق مسؤول
دفاعي امريكي اكد لنا بان انصار الله
الحوثيين نجحوا بالفعل بتوجيه ضربه
صاروخيه تحديدا بصاروخ بالستي مضاد
للسفن اصاب ناقله لما يوصف يسمى بالبضائع
السائبه او بالك كارير اثناء وجودها في
جنوب البحر الاحمر وهي السفينه التي تحمل
اسم زو جرافيا وترفع عالم
مالطا واشار هذا المسؤول الى ان السفينه
كانت لازالت قادره على الابحار واكملت
عبورها عمليه عبورها البحر الاحمر التبرير
الذي جاء في القصف الذي حصل صباح اليوم في
توقيت مبكر بتوقيت صنعاء ضد مواقع تابعه
لانصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن واستهدف
اربعه صواريخ بالستيه مضاده
للسفن قال المسؤول الامريكي ي بان الدفاعي
الامريكي بان هذه الصواريخ كانت معده
للاطلاق واشار الى انها تمثل كانت تمثل
تهديدا وشيكا وداه للسفن الشحن التجاري في
منطقه البحر الاحمر ولكن ايضا للسفن
الحربيه الامريكيه وبالتالي هناك تطور في
الموقف الامريكي بعد الضربات الاولى التي
وجهتها مع بريطانيا الى مواقع تابعه
لانصار الله في اليمن اليوم تؤكد الولايات
المتحده ان هذه القاعده البنيه التحتيه
سواء الصاروخيه او المسيرات هي تمثل تهديد
لبحر التها وبالتالي تعلل استهدافها في
اطار الدفاع النفس لكن الولايات المتحده
كانت بررت موجه الهجمات الاولى التي شنتها
ضد المواقع التابعه لانصار الله الحوثييين
بانها عمليا في سياق الردع من ناحيه ولكن
ايضا لوقف هجمات انصار الله الحوثيين ضد
الشحن البح وهي تعتبر ان هذه الهجمات لا
علاقه لها بما يجري في قطاع غزه اي الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه وان معظم السفن
التي يجري استهدافها غير مرتبطه باسرائيل
لكن من خلال الوقائع المستمره يبدو ان
انصار الله الحوثيون قادرون على الاستمرار
في ضرب السفن لا بل الابرز انهم تمكنوا
يوم امس للمره الاولى من ضرب سفينه تجاريه
امريكيه بمعنى ان ما سعى الامريكيون لوضع
حد له لاستهداف جزء من السفن المتوجهه الى
اسرائيل كما يقول انصار الله الان امتد
ليشمل ايضا السفن التجاريه الامريكيه
وبالتالي حتى هذه اللحظه يبدو انه عاد
بمردود عكسي وهذا في المقابل يشير الى ان
هناك اسئله كبيره تتعلق بالاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه وهل سوف تنجر الى ضربه مقابل
ضربه علما ان الرئيس بايدن كان يتعرض
لضغوط داخليه كبيره ليقوم بشيء ما ضد
هجمات انصار الله ايمانك فادي منصور مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من واشنطن واشكر محمد
العطاب مراسل الجزيره كان معنا من صنعاء